welcome to this video to be different
you notice immediately and it's probably
my first full HD video because I'm
trying to capture the whole on of ICC's
window here then the dash of software's
window usually that you only see then at
the bottom in the middle which is a 720p
video but i have this time captured the
whole thing the reason is that i had
some comments on the 15 minutes games
and can there were questions why I don't
play a better opposition in 15 minute
the problem is simply that I also wrote
some replies but the questions keep
popping up so I figure video is better
and it's simply a problem of this rating
pool being relatively small and this is
why I started this video tube to show
some of the the details behind that it's
also probably better to understand some
things about the games okay um this is
the whole software and I'm going here on
the right hand side with the mouse to
show this this video this own window
first it's them it's a list of all the
title players online sorted by rating
the rating displayed here for icc is the
five-minute rating i can choose what
waiting at light to show i'm doing five
minute because this is what what the
blitz games are played in you see mere
in the middle of this list note that
this only title players not all all
players and i have about 2500 again
you'll see the videos that bring me to
that i have some something plate in the
meantime okay so this is a me here and
you'll see that there's quite a number
of players above that many grand masters
here swat italic
alexander goldene are more night off
yeah a number of GM's and here also EMS
GM's below that in writing um the
general rank laminated fear we can do a
do a list here in the other video this
is this way five I cannot I can I need
to I simply have problems too this
commands oh I need to type it out drank
five minutes so this shows me among the
whole pack I'm number 54 on the server
of active active five-minute players
this means that this players must have
played them age rated games i think in
the last 10 days something like that so
there are much more players that are not
active but this is some among them the
players that are usually online you
notice that there are opponents that pop
up in the video see i like this guy i
have played of course your yard bird to
sarnia me LC con i played him before
endless fighter i played many my way
yeah you know the guys so this is the
five-minute pool there are many players
some at 4000 on total so I'm number
fifty four out of four thousand so this
is some okay yeah but now let's compare
this to 15 minutes and this is some a
big difference if we only look at the
title players the list is by far short
and among title players online I'm
actually number one at the moment ahead
of many other im's GM's they don't play
often I mean this only means they have a
rating in 15 minute and this is the way
they are sorted I can also
this rank thing for 15 minutes and
notice I was fifty four and five minute
and here number six total so there are
some players above that who were
actively play zhou shi i think i played
him in 15 minute hase begged becerra i
played him also but in one of the
earlier videos war heart I don't know
very high rating in 15 minute um yeah
you see that I'm much much higher here
it's not not like me playing better or
something it's simply a matter of
players involved in playing and the next
question you can post yourself how many
games are actually played if we mess
command for that as well it is called
games I had it before maybe I can hear
this is the list of current 15-minute
games played this continuation means the
game is finished they only look at it in
and after analysis post-mortem analysis
like I usually do in the individuals and
this is the whole bunch of games just
another 12 games or something and note
the ratings involved 1800 2017 16 this
is all of it there's no kind of filter
or so on it so they're simply very
simply very little interest in this time
control and at the moment if I would
start a game here pressing the 15-minute
button I would get players of this level
simply back there are no others um the
rating pool of five minute and three
minute is simply much much deeper if we
look at title players so let's say three
minute I don't play three minutes so
often but but but they are simply much
more titletitle players in there they
are also more overall place in depth
with a decent rating it's simply a
matter of the number of players involved
and I have no way to choose who I get I
mean if
enter now with 15 minute I get one of
those type of players i mean not those
because they actually play a game at the
moment but um similarly created players
and if you know coming and challenge no
not not now maybe later 31 mm-hmm if you
know a different site to play on where
the 15 minute games are more frequent
are usually stronger I might consider
two to play there but I really need to
have a hard time to believe that on
other side it's much much better simply
because I see sister has a very good
pool of players and done I tried chess
calm and the other sides and they are
not better in this respect but maybe I'm
missing something so feel free to
comment on on that um yeah that that's
that's it basically I just wanted to
show then the difference of rating pools
and the reason why I cannot really do
much about it um I don't mind really to
play those games so once in a while and
because they are quite often really
instructive even if it is for the
relatively big mistakes that the
opponents make but I can assure you I
have recorded a number of 15-minute
games for the next next days and while
there are some some drastic once they
are somewhere there's a good fight and
they're very much worth watching in my
opinion two or three of them are really
good in my opinion I mean like
outstanding was really satisfied with
with the games and think oh they have a
very good very good instructional value
okay thanks for watching I hope you like
this this information and he also got
some impression how this actually looks
like
okay thanks for watching